The Joe Rogan experience. Well, I said,
we were talking before and you were
trying to tell me that you were lazy.
I'm like, fuck you. I saw
that thing that you did,
that documentary where you ran a series
of marathons in a row with no training
at all.
And I remember thinking before that I had
this opinion of you and the opinion of
you was your funny guy. You're
a funny comedian. Um, you,
you have good stand up.
You obviously work hard at it.
But then I saw that and I was like,
oh, okay, there's something going on.
They're like, yeah, those are the
different kinds of human being,
the kind of human being they could push
themselves into doing that day after day
after day.
And I looked at your feet where your
skin was literally falling off and you're
taping everything up and um,
that's a,
that's a person that's got,
you have an iron will like that's a very
unusual will for a comedian who doesn't
really exercise. Like when you
were doing, I mean you were,
I mean you may be exercised a little
bit, but you weren't in shape. Now,
and you decided to run, how many
marathons in a way was at the UK one?
Was it the first one? Yeah,
that was 43 and 51 days.
43 marathons in a row in 51 days
with no training at a deaf way.
I did have training, six weeks
training. Yeah. Which is not a lot,
but they di they said that,
you know,
sometimes if you want a math and you
should train for nine months before that.
Yeah. And I felt, well I fucking
got to do 43 that's going to be,
I haven't been training forever. I can't
be bothered with that. So I, but you know,
and it's happening in your civil,
in maybe an any will. Uh, I, I,
I'm kind of some somewhat encyclopedic
about you civil war and revolution motor,
but world we'll too, but try
on the spot training, you know,
training as you go along.
That's what I did.
The first 10 Madison's
trains you for the next 33.
What was it like when you go
over the first day though?
The first marathon you must've, okay.
Fuck. No. First Day is okay. Well,
it's all in your head. There's a, um,
more mental than it is physical.
And so the first math that I've heard
of people who are running managers run,
walk, staggered, not very
fast. Get it done. Boom.
The second math in his weight cause you
go, I've done one, I'm on the second.
And you can't really rejoice.
You can punch the sky.
You can't put a metal right in your neck.
You're already,
you've got up at five or six
in the morning and you'll,
it's midday and you're,
you're going through your second one
and then let's do the third one and then
you'll do the fourth one.
And then it was raining and my feet was
shredding and I, the moisture it was,
yes, it may be too soft and they were
rubbing on the, on the running shoes.
And I didn't know how to,
how do I fix it when I'm actually
wearing on it all the time.
So we started bathing and surgical spirit,
which you call something else. Um, it's,
it's a, it's a ethanol
methanethiol. Anyways,
it's some sort of alcoholic
spirits and it uh,
it takes the moisture
out of your feet and um,
so it became like stones. It's
kind of like we should, um, uh,
anyway,
if anyone does lift up surgical spare,
if you Google it now you'll see what
it's called in America, but it's,
it's some sort of alcoholic
thing that just removes moisture.
And so it made my feet, my toes,
like little stones and kind of tough.
And actually that got us through.
And then I started and also apparently,
cause I did 27 mountains in 27 days
in South Africa in 2016. And that was,
the temperatures were crazy on that,
but it seems that the body will switch
on a healing property that we've got
latent in ourselves that we don't
use and you will heal quicker at,
you will heal faster the more you get.
So I got you get stronger in both the
British one and the South African one.
I got stronger as I went on the
first 10 days of the other key thing.
And after that it's kind of easy to,
you're used to it.
Your body just adapts in the understands.
Yep.
This crazy ass hole is going to
do crazy also, and the brain goes,
what kind of math and shall we run today
as opposed to what the fuck are you
doing? What kind of marathon? Yeah. Well,
I think that's what the brain's
dead because the first day is going,
you're going to do what? This marathon,
but be okay. The second database guy,
now we're going to, we're doing another
one third day, fourth day, fifth day.
This is insane. And then the
data in the brain is going, okay,
you're on this kind of kick or
something. I understand. Let's,
let's try a better amount of this.
Don't push it too hard. You know, you,
the brain starts talking to the body
and somehow it levels out around about
Maine and then they get surreal math at
18 raft 23 I remember marathon 31 that
was a lovely man. It's just so
weird. Yeah, but it was fun.
And you own the road,
you know a woody Guthrie.
This land is our lands on his mind. Land.
The you become like, it's your land.
It's like,
oh,
it's everybody's land because you're
running on the roads of this country.
I grew up in and you feel that
the roads, the fields, the birds,
I didn't listen to any music. I want
it slightly a safety thing for traffic,
but also you could hear everything
that's going on. Birds a river's running.
There was,
I ran possibly his house.
This isn't about day two and there was a
river running there and it went through
the back of this guy's garden and
he said, oh, hello, and I say,
can I went and visited him and I washed
my feet in the river and then I put the
socks back on and I carried on running.
I thought I can, you can do weird things.
I took blackberries out of the
bushes like I did when I was a kid.
It just became effective Pharell
this holistic or feral marathons.
That's what I was doing. It's not run.
It's not people shouting from the side.
No one cares really,
which is fine.
And I'm just wrapped up in that
this other place. Um, and it was,
it's beautiful. I mean,
it's really zen. Well,
it seems like it would change you like
accomplishing something like that.
Like on the last day, the last
run, when you crossed the line,
what was that feeling like? Wow, this is
a pitch you brought up that picture got,
they put up some flags and stuff.
That was beautiful.
I tried to do it a five hour marathon.
Now if you know the speeds is two hours
is what they're trying to break that.
So this is really slow.
But then having done 42 marathons,
it's maybe it's fair and uh, I,
I missed it by about 30 seconds,
but it was,
it was beautiful to finish it.
I was really quite strong all the way
through. I didn't at any time. That was,
that was good.
In South Africa though.
I did 27 and 27 days salute to
Nelson Mandela's 27 years in prison.
And Day five they put me in hospital
because they thought my kidneys were given
up. And you experiencing Rhabdo?
Is that what you know about? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Your first book ever talked
to WHO's done it about rhabdomyolysis?
Yeah, I got Rhabdo in 2012.
Um, how'd you get that?
I was on a, uh, anti-cholesterol
drug just to sort of health drug.
Your cholesterol is a bit high tech.
The thing what's today and side
effect is rubbed my license,
which I couldn't spell being dyslexic
and I was peeing Brown p and,
and uh, did it. No real pain. Lot
of lethargy. I was really tired.
I thought this is a bit weird and this
is without exercise you were getting in,
uh, that was on marathon
three amount than four.
So I had trained,
I trained before that.
I had done some training before that one
a bit weird with my training, but yeah,
so there wasn't a huge amount of training
before that one, but a third mouth and,
and I started paying a bit of Brown.
But this was not through the whole
series of marathons or it was, no, well,
I tried to do South Africa twice in 2012
was my first one after day four on an
anti cholesterol drug,
uh,
trying to control my cholesterol and I
started bringing brown p and then they
said,
you've got to go to a hospital now the
guys that you got to put fluids through
you,
you have to go see a specialist.
Especially said you can't continue this
27 thing because you have to get all
this stuff out of your system. Otherwise
the kidneys, because the it shreds the,
you know, the shirts are muscles into
the bloodstream, clogs up kidneys,
kidney failure. Very dangerous. A lot
of fighters get it. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
I'm a fighter. Died from it. Um, recently
in Boston. In the Massachusetts area.
Yeah. It's, uh, it's apparently, um,
something that happens when
fighters overtrain as well.
Like sometimes they're not doing it
scientifically so they're not analyzing
their heart rate or heart rate variability
and they don't know that they haven't
really truly recovered and they continue
to push themselves because they want to
prepare harder.
Yes,
they have this sort of mental
mindset just train harder and you'll,
you'll be better off. But that's not
necessarily the case of your body.
Can't physically keep up with the
recovery and sometimes they'll go into a
flight overtrained and then they wind
up getting robbed dough from the fight.
It's happened several times and
it's caused a few deaths. Yeah.
Well they said this,
you said you carry on running it running
now in 2012 and you won't make it to
2016 did you get off that medication?
Yeah, I would think that all that running,
you wouldn't need that medication,
I would have thought. But you know,
they check you out and you say [inaudible]
just at the little China fuckers,
you be on this for the rest of your life.
That stuff's gives a shit out of me.
They'll statens right.
It's, it gets a scary place.
But 2016 day five bloods were
looking a bit weird day off.
So Day 27 I did devil Madison and
that was kind of an interesting day.
So you run one marathon
or you're lost Davey run,
you've only done 25 minutes in
and said it's the day 27 so,
and when you go through that finishing
the final flag where w either you should
be waving flags, you've got another
marathon to go and it's just, yeah,
I might Brian like, oh, this is
kinda good, but you've got to,
it's 90 k you're going to do
today. Ignore it, carry on.
And it was a rough, rough all day. That's
five hours. And then another five hours,
five hours plus five hours
plus in the end it was six. Uh,
I took 11 hours and 50
minutes to run 90 [inaudible].
So I did double marathon in 11
hours. 10 minutes. Damn good. Yeah,
it was good enough. And
this, they've got a,
they've got a comrades
marathon in South Africa,
which is 90 [inaudible] and they've
got a 12 hour cutoff. So I said,
I will do 90 K in 12 hours.
The double marathon was 84 and then I
did another six k after I'd finished that
last moment.
Must have been orgasmic when you finished.
It must have been incredible.
Finishing the 84 was beautiful year finish
at the steps of Nelson Mandela Statue.
Right.
He was made president and that
was a bit of an and rough,
I'd have to speed up in the last
hour because of complications.
So I actually got faster.
If you had,
have you ever done the thing where you're
knackered and neck and said now go,
why'd you have to speed up?
There was a wind,
it was a thing called sport relief is
doing it for, so it was raising money and,
and I wanted to finish
inside the camera window.
They had a window until three
15 South African time. Um,
police escorts would needed certain bits,
otherwise you'll get car jack things and,
and it's,
and you won't survive this big. So
I said, can't we just ignore that?
The car jacking thing? No,
you can't ignore it. So I
said, okay, stop the clock,
put me in the thing, drive
me tutorials, stopped me off.
And then I'll run there and
we'll just continue it on there.
So we had to do that.
So we got behind because I wasn't running
cause that'd be driven across this
dangerous period of part point of
road to be dropped to Pretoria.
And then I just had to run the kilometers
off. So they have like a car jack area.
Yeah, they have in there is
where this kind of out there.
There's no one really out there and
you just go along there and they'll,
you know, anything can happen. So, um, my,
my field producer fixer, he was
just saying, we don't do this, just,
you can't go there.
So I said,
well just get me closer to the finishing
line and then I'll just run them.
It doesn't really matter
where I'm running now.
We noticed Paratore now we'd need to
finish, I need to just run that distance.
So I ran the distance itself,
but the time had got behind.
So I had to speed up from 7.5 kilometers
an hour to 10 kilometers in now.
So an extra third, this boot,
which was kind of evil. Now.
I'm owned a lot of that though. I
just, I was just a moaning, whining.
Oh dear God, I got through this, but I
was never considering not doing it. And,
and I got the um,
the live feed to,
to London finished at quarter past and
we got there about 30 minutes passed.
We had about two minutes and they just
caught it before they went off at,
it was like, you know, like in a film,
you know, it was perfectly designed.
I just knew if I got that
probably I get more money,
raise more money and extra grand
because we've seen this idiot finish.
He's actually doing it here
though. Um, so that was beautiful.
And then I talked to the, this very
interesting thing because you know,
if you're talking to PR, it was a
press. I talked to the press after that,
but it's a Sunday.
And so they kept talking.
Normally they say we can't talk anymore.
We've got two minutes and then we're
going to talk to important people go away.
That's what normally happens if you're
talking to live press and national press.
But I was on thing and they just kept
talking to me because obviously a slow
news day, nothing was
happening. And they'll say,
we've got this idiot who's just
run, you know, 27 marathons.
And they kept asking me other questions,
what favorite color do you have and
what, what, how, how big are your legs?
Legs? Yeah. I just, I don't know what
they were asking me, but in the end,
these two interviews I did that
with national prayer. I just said,
I'm going to go away now. I'm going to
stop this. I had to stop my own interview,
which I've never done in my life and I
realize they've just got no one else to
talk to that desperate.
Did you notice a big change in public
perception of you once you completed those
marathons? Yeah, the um, yeah,
the certain community and if you're
transgender guy and you come out,
certain people go worry. But I,
I crossed into a line of, well,
if you're going to do that, and I
hate, I know you do some comedy,
you do the drama stuff, we think
you're a bit bonkers and out there.
But fair play. I've got this
sort of, I got to pass it.
Fair play to you if you're going to do
that. And I was trying to do selection,
you know, SAS, they have selection,
your Delta forces, Navy Seals,
they all have this thing that can you
just go on and on and on and it's the
stamina thing.
And,
and that was my civilian
selection for my own whatever,
several forces. Just to
understand yourself. Yeah. I uh,
you're out there running around.
I would have a,
there was a guy with a gun next to,
it'll be a good shot.
He said he knew how to shoot things
and the, um, I don't know. I,
I played my cards,
you know,
sometimes you play your cards well it
must have been kind of exhilarating to
others. Something about it. Right. Well
there, there was, I was talking to the um,
[inaudible] I just, I went out cause you
know, obviously they were not dangerous.
There's holiday non-dangerous ones.
It was actually the first day and the
battery's about marathon 10 or 11 or
something. And I felt, you know,
once you're over the 10 mark and
I've never got there, you know,
if you've done the whole South African
thing and failed and people were tweeting
about me, Eddie is, you know,
Africa kicked your ass. You
know, you just go with Tia.
This is Africa. Take us on where
huge fucking constantly, hey,
that's what I say.
[inaudible] no, Africa. Yeah,
it's a big African because Africa
is, did you tell them, hey man,
I was on medication.
My [inaudible] didn't really matter.
That was just in that whining.
So I just had to come back and I've
tried three times to come back and then I
came back and, uh, three times. Yeah,
I kept trying. Can we set the day that,
can we get back and do the thing?
But there's no,
we haven't got enough money
to be able to do that,
that won't be able to set up your
keywords and then suddenly it's on,
it's on it's own. And I didn't,
I couldn't train again. And uh,
so I thought, let's just go get it done.
And then day five was in the hospital.
Day Six was in the hospital as well.
For how after two thirds of the marathon
on day six, I had to go to hospital.
Say for what? Um, well, it kept
what happened? Uh, they, my,
my train, my doctor had gone
away, but my train of thought, um,
he thought I just didn't look good.
It was, you know, 35, 38 degrees,
whatever, you know, and I'm used to, what
does that took one? Oh, sorry. Fahrenheit.
Yeah, I'd say one 10,
one 15, seven up there.
And um,
I was not used to that and so I was, I
would have made it, I feel, but he didn't,
he felt,
he wanted me to see an extra.
So I saw on the fraud logist I
didn't even know what the word meant,
but nephrologist is a kidney expert.
I thought that would be a renal expert,
but no, he's a nephrologist
and it's very cool. Black Dude.
And he was there in South
Africa and eastern East London.
It's called is the city. So it's the big
place and he's going, what are you doing?
Who are you? I'm running for Mandela.
What I want to do this thing and okay.
And uh, he said it's okay. We've checked
out your kidneys, your right, your bloods.
Uh, it's, it's a hydration.
Hydration is terrible.
So I'm going to put three liters into
you and you'll be paying like a horse all
night. And I didn't pee once. So,
ah, that's what you're saying.
You need some hydration and a,
and after that it got better with,
and so they 11, I got into
national, this national park,
so there's no one else there, just me
and animals and this, the, you know,
the security people and whatever with
me. And uh, it was kind of beautiful.
It was just beautiful and
that the sun was great,
a sunset going down and there was a
rainstorm as well in the middle of it.
There were wild animals out there.
I don't know, I just felt, okay,
this is n weird place of beauty. And,
and also knowing I'm getting stronger,
I'm getting stronger. I've gone
through the barrier. Um, and I also,
because I'd read, I'd run four marathons,
then a day off. And then the fifth,
sixth day I ran two thirds or math.
So I'd run forward two
thirds marathons in six days,
which is not good numbers for your head.
You need five and five or
something in something.
But for to 2016 it just didn't work.
And then they run another marathon that,
and I said,
hang on,
I've got to run a marathon and a third
and get these numbers matching up.
So I caught up the third marathon and
then it was always day seven and I've run
six, eight marathons in nine days.
It was always one day behind.
So I thought last day I'll do a double
marathon and that'll be a good climactic
and of my South African thing.
What is,
what is going on with your mind when
you're doing this because you're not
listening to any music, you know, in your,
in this sort of meditative state where
you're just left foot, right foot,
left foot, right foot, breathe
in, breathe. Um, yeah, it's,
I'm saying it's kind of zen but it's not
in a kind of like I'm listening to my
heartbeat or anything. It's more like I,
I just feel uh,
yeah,
just some sort of beautiful thing of
maybe cause that's what we used to be as
humans. So maybe I'm reaching
back into some pars memory.
We humans just used to be out on the
plains and we were looking for honey wild
honey or barriers, root stuff and, and if
we could trap something we'd see either,
I don't know what,
I can't quite work out what it is,
but I just find it beautiful and I do
know what you're getting vitamin D in your
getting stronger from that. Um,
somebody wants read my hand.
I never do the hand palm reading but I
was at a Halloween party and there was a
palm reader that there's, I'll
try, I'm in a good place, let's,
let's read my hand and I can't
remember what she said, et Cetera.
You need to get out more easily
outside more. And I thought, okay,
I always felt that I need to be out back
doing stuff. Cause when I was a kid,
I live for soccer, for football, I used
to run like a crazy, I love that game.
And then from the age of 12 I went to a
school that didn't play it and I never
played sports. This is one of
my gifts to myself. Accident.
I think from the age of 12 you know,
you're in your teenage years,
your bones really moving and setting.
And at that time I was hardly doing
anything. So I think my knees,
I've never gone. People say running
in the knees, my knees are not gone.
I run a whole theory about the, the
heel of the foot, which it should never,
you know, you should, you know,
sprinters are always on your toes.
All running should be on the toes.
And I think if the heel hits,
that's what causes the Neils just
needs a script. I'm, it could be wrong,
there's no, no, that's correct. That's
not how people were supposed to run.
That was actually changed by Nike.
They developed a running shoe with a
fat heal and they changed the way people
run. They changed the gate
and it's responsible for a
lot of injuries. I think so.
And I noticed on horses,
if you look for the heel of a horse,
it's right up by that bum cause
that that, that, that toes,
you know the hoof is the toes and then
you go all about that leg and right by
the bum is that's the heel that's just
an enormously long foot and you go,
well that's never going to hit the ground
and a dog's done at cats tender it.
We are the ones that use this heel thing
obviously to initially to for walking
to make us balanced when we went from the
chimpanzee. Good real estate into the,
you know, we need to. But even then, I
mean most people if you just give them,
if they're barefoot like children for
example, like one of the things that I,
I was reading this book about barefoot
running and how important it is to
develop this. And then Mo, most
people that have problems from that,
they're really having problems because
their feet don't have strong muscles in
them because of the atrophy.
And the way they were describing a regular
running shoes is essentially like a
cast and that you're,
you're so used to being protected in this
calf that everything sort of just gets
mushy inside of it. And then you're
also striking down on the hill,
which is a very unnatural thing.
And when I watch my kids run,
like my kids were run with me sometimes
and they naturally know to run on the
balls of their feet. That's
how they naturally run. Yeah.
And when people start running,
he'll first, that's where
all the problems come in.
It's just not a normal way
for people to run. Yeah.
And I was also in initiative in South
Africa running on certain roads services
where they'd just dropped instead of
doing a tar macadam kind of covering, uh,
they had just put rocks,
obviously some Lori had come along.
This truck had just dropped rocks out
of the back to sort of hold together the
in the rainy times and
very uneven surface,
very hard or the foot.
And I was uh,
I was doing these very thin soled
running very thin sole. The shoes.
What kind of shoes are you running with?
Um, well I kept changing them now, so I,
but with the vibrams or then
the of vive. Oh, barefoot ones.
And I'll see you running in barefoot,
running marathons and barefoot shoes.
Well initially I was, and then my train
it, I, it just got so hard that my turn,
I said, look, you got to wear these. And
then I left it to them to choose Mike,
my physio, and he was Olympic
level. So he said, right,
these are going to be better for that. I
prefer you not to be in this. So I said,
okay, you tell me what
she used to wear. I'll,
I'll take care of running the bathroom.
But I do remember seeing little South
African children running on the roads next
to me where they called,
Hey, we run with you.
And they had completely nothing on their
feet and they can deal with these sharp
rocks. Well I thought we already show
him. I was every few steps. Great. Whoa.
Oh Wow. And they would just, yeah,
and they would just, uh, they had,
they were laughing and running
along. Nope. Cause they,
their fee that built up like,
and it's very, this very,
how say I see South Africa.
Yeah. This is a weird,
watch this now it's kind of
fun because I go right back.
I ran with flags. That's,
that's a beautiful thing.
And I was running an Eastern Cape
and they are looking at white guy.
It was a white guy doing,
and this is very rural area.
So I would say more low molar.
That was in the African National Park.
That was the rain. That was
the um, the uh, they uh,
where the rhinestone happened cause
he thunder and lightning. That's the,
that's the truck there on the left.
You can see the thing.
And this guy just turned up out of the
blue to track me down. What did he give?
You know, just give me a letter saying
thank you for doing stuff, but I,
if I ran with the flag and I, and I
said Molo to people and like led to say,
how are you? And, and
in, in the Coosa Casa,
this guy seems like he's
wearing women's clothes as well.
He's wearing a skirt and I think he's a
transgender guy with less hair than me.
And yeah, he's bald, but
he's a transgender guy. Yeah.